how tantalizing to see all your shining
young faces on this auspicious
day I am Dr volumia GA your humble head
game maker in charge of the war
department and all its Affiliated
concerns I am honored to introduce to
you the creator of The Hunger Games
themselves Dean Casa High bottom I have
summoned you all here
today for the 10th Annual reaping
ceremony in which we choose two children
from each
district throw into the capital Arena to
fight to the death in The Hunger Games I
am here to tell you that there has been
a change this year one final assignment
to prove your worth it's a story that
takes place of 64 years before the first
installment of the movies and focuses on
young snow look at
you your makeshift shirt and your two
tight shoes trying desperately to fit in
when I know the Snows don't have a pop
to piss
in snow is being groomed to become the
man he becomes as a mentor Your Role is
to turn these children into spectacles
not survivors persuade
them to perform through the camera Lucy
gray and the one who snow because the
mentor for and also falls in love with
there's a very naturalistic quality to
her but she's a charmer she's a musician
she's a performer she's kind of the anti
catness she's part of the cvy this kind
of roving band of musicians Snow's never
met anybody like her that romance
between them makes snow question
everything he was raised to
believe I think there's a natural
goodness born into us all you don't
really
you can either cross that line into
evil or not and it's our last work to
stay on the right side of that line part
of the Love Story starts to fall apart
and that is part of the creation of who
he becomes it's the things we love most
that destroy us most everybody that I
work with is coming back Trish
Somerville is doing the costumes for
this movie y Willams who shot catching
the Mocking Jays the one new person that
I'm really excited about is ulie Hanish
who's the production designer we talked
about the sort of look in the feel of
the movie The visuals of this movie will
be very different than mocking jay but
there's real consistency in terms of the
capital architecture we get to sort of
reinvent the world of penm to sort of
deconstruct what the games are that
we're sort of used to and go back in
time it wasn't until I read it that I
saw how much music was actually in here
and we met with Dave Cobb he's a
fantastic songwriter and producer it's
going to be fun to take all this history
of British Isles music and southern
music and mash it all together in this
dystopian way in this future James
Newton Howard it's my fourth Hunger
Games Film with him the musical
opportunity is
great relationships are very powerful in
the movie the good and the bad are very
clearly laid
out for James and I it was really fun to
explore a new sound for The Hunger Games
sometimes it's foot stomping and rousing
and sometimes It's haunting mysterious
and a lot of that is based on the kind
of period of the movie itself but
there's going to be some familiar
elements as well Hanging Tree is back in
a completely different iteration and
treatment here we get to see Lucy gray
coming up with it for the first
time are
you are
you coming to the tree where I told you
to run so we'd both be
free strange things did happen here a
stranger would it be if we met up
at in a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree